distance learning's certainly a
challenge for kids everywhere
and in north las vegas it is for those
who don't have the internet
last year the city opened micro
classrooms to help with that and there
is now a new location
hector mejia has the latest from the
southern nevada urban micro academy
the city of north las vegas plans to
keep the micro classrooms
open even after ccsd starts reopening
some classrooms
on march 1st for some students and here
this is one of the newest places the
third location
students are learning math and joining
us this afternoon we have miss kim to
explain all of the requirements
good afternoon to you how are you good
afternoon i'm good so tell us about the
requirements students need to be
residents of north las vegas yes they
need to be residents of north las vegas
or the children of first responders or
essential workers
on that note what are we learning right
now what's the unit student's
relationship
in honor of black history month it's
wonderful that we are doing a little
curveball
and not learning just about the typical
people that we always celebrate
thinking outside the box yes we're going
a little deeper and i'm having
the students learn about people who have
never been recognized and that most
don't know about and within the
african-american community
community in all minorities and for you
know the students here in north las
vegas who were having a really hard time
learning from home what are you hearing
from them
oh i hear that they're very very happy
to have guides
and instructors that can help them to
capture what they are expected to know
and to learn which is really important
because they kind of were self-teaching
themselves at home which isn't fair
and lastly you know what are your
thoughts we are in a rec center that's
been transformed into several smaller
micro classrooms
i think it's wonderful because it really
represents the community
and so i think the entire effort shows
that it does truly take a village thank
you for your time we'll be posting all
of these details on our website
reporting from north las vegas hector
mejia 8 news now